t
à l'étranger.
Voicieieieie Langlois.
♪ ♪ ♪
ROMÉO SAGANASHchchchchchchchchcs
- Aussitôt que j'arrive en
forêt, je change complètement.
Je me sens protégé, je me sens
- Les Cris de la Baie-James
sont profondément atta
leur territoire : des rivières
majestueuses, des forêts
battus pendant 30 ans devant
trtrtrtrtribunaux contre les cos
à blanc des forestières.
Roméo Saganash chassait
près de Waswanipi.
- Un printemps, je suis arfofoft
était totalement coupée.
C'est un choc.
- En l'an 2000, la cour donne
raisonststststststststststststst
leurs droits. Le jugement force
Québec à négocier.
BERNARD LANDRY,
pr- Le gouvernement du Québec et
les Cris consentent à cesser
leurs poursuites judiciaires de
plusieurs milliards de dollars.
sûr, Bernard Landry a très bien
compris qu'il y avait
une industrie entière qui
était en péril.
un des principaux architectes
de l'entente.
- Nous faisons la paix des
- Quand l'entente de principe
est sign'A'A'A'A'A'Assemblée
nationale, le grand chef
lui demande, juste avant de
une phrase en français dans
so
guerre, nous faisons la paix
des braves." E Cette entente a e
permis que ce soit normal pour
un peuple autochtone de vouloir
son autonomie, de pouvoir
territoire et du développement
des ressources du territoi
- Les Cris abandonnont des
poursuites de 8 milliards et
construise une nouvelle centrale
en dérivant la Rupert,
plus grandes rivières au monde.
C'est un immense sacrifice,
En échange, Québec promet
4 milliards sur
des milliers d'emplois.
- Pour ce propriétaire d'un café
à Caiaiaiaiaiaiaiaix des braves
est un gros chèque de bien-être
social, qui étouffe l'instinct
- Le monstre dont parle
l'homme d'affaires, c'est
la bureaucratie crie, qui
Éducation, santé, services
sociaux, système
police, conseils de bandes :
ces services fournissent 80 %
et contribueraient à creusert t.
- C'est sûr que, lorsquetu créee
dans une société, ça crée
une classe de ququququququququq.
PAKESSO MUKASH, ex-ambassadeur,
Cons. jeunesse nation crie
- Donc, positif? Oui, il y a
du travail, il y a d C C C C CÇé
quoi? De dehors, on pense
qu'on est riche. Je
qu'on est riche. Ça a l'air
qu'on est riche, mais
si tu perds ta langue et
ta culture, el
ta richesse?
- Pakesso Mukash avait abandonné
contre l'entente. 20 ans plus
tard, seonononononononononont
concrétisées.
- Pour moi, la paidedededededede
deux rivières, puis c'étaitvrai.
Puis, ça a beaucoup blessé
notre génération.
plus autonomes dans la gestion
de la forêt? Coupe-t-on encore
trop d'arbres?
- Selon moi, oui.
Mais l'objectif, avec la paix
la parole à ceux et celles qui
rrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrritoire,
de nous dire où, s'il doit y
avoir des coupes forestièreapaps
le choix, puis ils se font
tasser. Il y a même
des communautés, je pense que
y y y y y y y y y y y y y y y é
pour une des mines, puis il
personne qui a consulté
les trappeurs.d'assimilation, pe
notre gouvernement tra
notre peuple de la même façon
que le gouvernement du Québec,t.
- Pour les artisans de l
des braves, l'entente a donné
aux Cris un poids politique qui.
Pour les opposants,
cette autonomie n'a pas servi
à mieux p